i
i have jokingly had like a roster
because i'm like right all these men
that i've been casually seeing have told
me you're not gonna be my girlfriend
don't get attached i'm like okay cool so
what i'll do is i'll make sure do you
not get attached actually um
ah well i'm yeah i'm cognizant enough to
be respectful and to know that if you
tell me i'm not gonna change your mind
i'm not gonna change you yeah
um so i'm like okay so i'll i'll okay
i'll make sure then that i'm dating
other people so if one of you ends it or
pisses me off or isn't available or you
know i'll just sort of spread through
the cycle so it's almost like you have
more as almost like a defense mechanism
so you don't get your feelings hurt yeah
like my attachment i don't know what my
attachment style is but it's probably
like very anxious
but
if i then i'm i'm a really open book i
don't lie to anyone i'm very much like
okay well if i'm dating you i'm also
dating other people but all of these
guys who have told me outright amy
you're not gonna be my girlfriend i'm
not gonna be serious about you don't get
feelings for me i'm like okay so